les femmes pourront désormais nager
seins nus dans les piscines de la ville
de gottingen en allemagne cette
initiative a été mise en place suite à
un incident survenu il ya plusieurs mois
dans une piscine de la ville voici ce
qu'il s'est passé en fait à l'automne
2000 21 agents de la piscine avait
demandé à une personne torse nu qu'il
considérait comme une femme de se
recouvrir le torse cette personne avait
refusé car est identifié comme étant de
genre masculin conséquence la piscine a
interdit à cette personne d'accéder à
son établissement cet incident a
provoqué un vif débat dans la ville et
la mairie a finalement tranché cette
semaine en annonçant l'ouverture de la
baignade torse nu pour toutes et tous la
mesure entrera en vigueur à partir du
1er mai et sera appliqué au moins
jusqu'à la fin de la pratique du sein nu
sera cependant limitée aux huitièmes la
mairie s'est justifié sur cette
limitation en précisant que cela ne
devait pas compromettre les cours de
natation scolaire en semaine